bonsoir et bienvenu pour le 78 lactu
nous sommes le 18 septembre voici les
titres qui seront développés au cours de
cette édition du Journal de la rédaction
la gare de Saint-Quentin enfin rénovée
c'était attendu depuis longtemps par les
usagers quelques 25000 par jour
l'inauguration vient d'avoir lieu ce
matin dans le cadre de la Semaine
européenne de la mobilité plus 14 % de
bénévoles en un peu moins de 3 ans
France bénévola a rendu publique sa
dernière enquête alors qu'une campagne
de communication est lancée en cette
rentrée nous ferons le point avec le
délégué régional de l'association en
plateau et puis le château de Versailles
c'est aussi une bande dessinée vous le
voyez le deuxè tome vient d'être lancé
depuis le site historique en présence
des auteurs et du PDG de la maison
d'édition glena l'image du jour c'est
l'autopartage à 550 ans Eveline qui fête
ses un an le 18 septembre 2012 50 twezy
de Renault étaient proposé à la location
moyennant 30 centim la minute des
véhicules bipl à prendre et à redéposer
au coin de votre rue et localisable
grâce à votre téléphone portable si vous
souhaitez vous inscrire pour bénéficier
de ce service rendez-vous dans la
boutique teway située à la gare de
Montini le
bretonne la gare de Montini justement on
y reste puisqu'elle vient d'être
inaugurée avec 25000 usagers par jour
sans rénovation importante depuis
1975 les locaux étaient devenus plus que
vétustes les travaux d'aménagement
extérieurs vont se prolonger jusqu'en
2017 reportage Antony Resche Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud les élus locaux découvrent la
nouvelle gare de 50 ans en Yveline la
salle des pas perdus est enfin dotée
d'une Signaléthique claire l'espace a
été décloisonné et les usagers peuvent
désormais acheter des billets
Transiliens ou grandes lignes sans
chercher leur chemin au point de vue de
l'affichage beaucoup mieux c'est vrai
qu'au début quand je suis arrivé ah
j'étais complètement paumé c'est clair
que même au niveau infrastructure rien à
dire c'est super on a implanté des
nouveaux panneaux
d'information pour les trains donc pour
indiquer d'où partent les trains et
l'information vraiment sur le trafic qui
ont aussi contribué à faciliter bah la
gestion des flus dans cette gare la gare
cinquentinoise n'avait pas connu de
rénovation importante depuis
1975 avec 25000 usagers par jour le
lifting de la station était devenu vital
pas encore unu mais on a refait le
revêtements de sol les plafonds tout ce
qui est lié à la sécurité l'éclairage la
signalitique l'ensemble des modalités de
de circulation verticale escalator on a
mis à niveau le parc des ascenseurs les
travaux de réaménagement de la salle des
pas perdus s'élève à 18800000 € financé
à 50 % par la Région Île-de-France et à
50 % par la SNCF à l'extérieur la rue
Joël leul et l'avenue de la gare sont
encore en chantier à l'horizon 2017 2018
la gare de 50 ans en Eveline pourrait
voir sa passerelle totalement réaménagée
pour donner un autre accès au
qu et que pensez-vous de cette nouvelle
gare justement nous sommes allés
recueillir vos réactions c'est notre
question du jour vos impressions voici
vos réponses elle est beaucoup mieux
c'est vrai qu'il y a quelques années
c'était dans un très mauvais état et
c'est vrai que maintenant ouais elle est
super franchement je la trouve bien et
surtout la bas nouvel escalator je le
trouve pas mal c'est plus facile d'aller
vers les clés c'est plus
et c'est beaucoup plus agréable on se
retrouve assez facilement on attend
juste que les travaux à la sortie soit
fini quoi c'est plus liible il y a déjà
beaucoup plus de il y a avant il y avait
pas de resto il y avait pas tout ça et
au point de vue de l'affichage beaucoup
mieux bah les couleurs l'agencement
comment ça a été organisé le design ouis
on a vraiment envie de d'y
venir la gestion de la région
Île-de-France pointé du doigt par deux
rapports de la chambre régionale des
comptes dans le collimateur notamment
l'absentéisme élevé et onéreux des
personnels techniques des lycées
d'Île-de-France dans certains
établissements la moyenne des absences
dépasse 45 jours par an soit près du
quart du temps effectif du travail de
ces agents le président PS Jean-Paul
Huchon de la région présentera ses
rapports aux différents élus lors de la
prochaine séance du Conseil régional les
26 et 27 septembre il s'engageraient
d'ors et déjà à adapter ces dispositifs
les nouveaux rythmes scolaires en place
depuis maintenant un peu plus de 2
semaines attrape notamment la mairie
voulait faire un point d'étape un bilan
avec les enseignants et leurs syndicats
une réunion s'est tenue hier mercredi en
mairie et il reste encore des
ajustements à faire yolen Torz et
Anthony
Resche la municipalité les a invité pour
faire le bilan de la rentrée les
enseignants de trappe très remontés on
on profité pour s'exprimer sur
l'organisation des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires leur constat est sans appel
selon eux la situation actuelle apporte
stress et confusion au au sein des
familles nous ce qu'on souhaiterait
c'est que enfin les acteurs de terrain
soient entendus par la municipalité et
que les choses ne se passent pas comme
elles se sont passées depuis le début
finalement reçu par la première adjointe
Janine Marie les enseignants ont mis sur
table tous les dysfonctionnements qu'ils
ont observé depuis la rentrée trop
d'horaires différents manque de locaux
ou encore manque d'organisation
l'adjointe évoque des incompréhensions
des deux côtés elle s'est engagée à
faire le tour de toute des écoles pour
observer l'organisation de la nouvelle
réforme pendant ce temps le maire lui a
reçu les directeurs
d'écoles culture les éditions glena ont
décidé de décliner le passé du château
de Versailles en bande dessinée
aujourd'hui sort le deuxème volet
intitulé l'ombre de Marie-Antoinette un
mélange des genres entre BD de
science-fiction et ouvrage historique
également scénariste dessinateur et
éditeur étaient au Grand Trianon pour le
lancement de cette bande dessinée cler
Cambier et le dimoine
une plongée dans l'univers du château de
Versailles du 18e siècle c'est ce que
nous propose cette bande dessinée
l'ombre de Marie Antoinette le tome 2
d'un triptique sur le château l'histoire
d'un jeune Américain qui se retrouve
propulsé en pleine révolution française
alors quoi de plus naturel que de
présenter cet ouvrage sur les lieux
mêmes de l'histoire scénaristes
dessinateur et éditeur étai hier au
Grand Trianon mais ce lieu leur était
déjà bien familier car tous les décors
de cette bande dessinée sont identiques
à l'original le pavillon dans lequel on
se trouve justement sur le tome 1 il
m'est arrivé de refaire justement les
les carreaux de fenêtrre parce qu'à
l'époque il y en avait deux fois plus
donc ça n'a pas échappé aux yeux du
conservateur un attachement aux détails
historiques mais également au fait un
conservateur du château a aiguillé les
auteurs sur les deux tomes réalisés car
ce triptique est coédité par les
éditions glena et le château de versaill
habituellement plus porté sur des
ouvrages d'histoire leur volonté était
d'ouvrir un petit peu un public plus
plus large avec ce support qui est la
bande dessinée qui est donc un art assez
populaire on va dire la volonté aussi de
ne pas présenter quelque chose de
purement historique mais la bande
dessinée permet de fictionner des
événements donc de rentrer dans un
univers où la la petite histoire
rencontre la la grande histoire nous
retrouverons ce mélange des genes pour
un dernier volet cette fois dans le
cercle de
Molière l'invité de cette édition du 18
septembre membre du 78 lactu Bernard
touboule bonsoir vous êtes délégué
régional Île-de France de France
bénévola on va parler du bénévola
justement avec vous une campagne de
communication débute pour faire
découvrir la variété du bénévolat tout
ça alors que l'on parle régulièrement de
crise de l'engagement de repli sur soi
surtout en période de crise alors est-ce
que crise il y a eston en période de
crise du bénévolat encore aujourd'hui
alors pas vraiment parce que nous avons
nous venons de réaliser une enquête avec
lesphob qui est sortie au mois de juin
on montre que 40 peu plus de 40 % des
Français de plus de 15 ans s'engagent
dans le bénévolat la même enquête
réalisée il y a 2 ans il y a 2 ans et
demi en septembre 2010 montrrait qu'il y
avait 36 % donc on a une progression
bien au contraire du bénévolat et
surtout chez les jeunes c'est les la
tranche des 15 25 15 35 ans qui
progressent le plus
euh plus 32 % c'est quand même assez
significatif comment ça s'explique que
ce soit les plus jeunes qui s'engagent
ça s'explique que d'une part parce que
déjà le taux d'engagement était faible
donc il y a une marge une bonne marge de
progression marge de progression ça
s'explique aussi par la le besoin qu'ont
les jeunes euh de rechercher du lien
social et le le l'engagement bénévole
c'est un créateur de lien social euh ça
s'explique aussi euh par le fait que les
jeunes dans cette période difficulté de
rechercher de l'emploi prennent le
bénévolent un petit peu comme à une
marche vers l'emploi c'est très souvent
euh dans en milieu associatif pour les
jeunes qui débutent hein on a fait tant
d'années d'étude on vous demande
qu'est-ce que vous avez déjà fait donc
si on débute on a rien fait donc ça
permet de rajouter des lignes au CV de
montrer en qu'on a expérience sur ça
permet de montrer non seulement déjà une
première expérience je crois que l'année
dernière lorsque vous m'aviez invité
j'avais évoqué le Passeport Bénévole
donc c'est tout à fait dans dans cette
lignée donc ça permet de montrer cette
première expérience et surtout ça
développe une qualité que de plus en
plus de recruteurs recherchent c'est le
développement du lien social aller vers
les autres travailler en équipe et c'est
aussi un des fondamentaux du bénévolat
de travailler en équipe vous parlez du
Passeport Bénévole pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas avec nous l'an dernier
lorsque nous avons évoqué le bénévolat
justement ce passeport c'est une
reconnaissance en fait passort en
fait c'est un outil qui permet de suivre
toutes les activités et formations qu'un
bénévole a suivi dans sa vie associative
qui est aujourd'hui reconnu comme un
document quasi officiel puisque ce
document est soutenu parpport à l'emploi
ministè de l'éducation de démarche de de
valeur des Acquis de l'Expérience alors
c'est amusant parce que vous parlez de
recherche de liens social pour les plus
jeunes en période de de développement
d'Internet de réseaux sociaux Twitter
Facebook non en fait les jeunes
souhaitent aussi se rencontrer
physiquement avoir des vrais échanges
phys aller vers les autres aller vers
les plus vers les plus anciens vers les
plus âgés on développe d'Illes a des
actions intergénérationnell donc c'est
besoin un petit peu de connaître de
connaître l'expérience des plus anciens
mais aussi de d'apprendre des compétence
de travailler en équipe d'être avec
leurs camarades récemment je vous en
prie je dis encore faut-il que les
associations puissent adapter aux jeunes
et oui voilà alors justement récemment
le président de France benéola votre
président déclaré il faudrait davantage
développer une pédagogie de l'engagement
c'est-à-dire rassurer les gens qui sont
prêts à s'engager mais qui ont peur
d'être embrigadé c'est aussi ça le
risque du bénévolat quand on s'engage
dans une association on se dit qu'on est
PI et point li cour on dit lorsqu'on
donne le petit doigt on donne le bras
entier pour nous l'engagement bénévole
des jeunes c'est leur faire découvrir ce
que les bénévolat et préparer les
bénévolle de demain on sait très bien
qu'entre 25 et 35 ans la plupart vont
s'arrêter de faire du bénévolat parce
qu'ils construisent leur vie personnelle
parce qu'ils pensent à leur vie
professionnel et la privilégie ce qui
est tout à fait normal mais plus tard
vers 35 40 ans et les chiffres que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure montrent que
ça ça augmente de nouveau à partir de 35
ans il y a une inquiétude tout de même
des associations qui est réelle même si
vous nous dites qu'il n'y a plus
vraiment de crise et qu'il y a cette
engagement il y a un collectif
d'association citoyennes qui appelle à
une mobilisation le 21 septembre
prochain il y aura des rencontres et
puis également une demande d'engagement
aux candidats des municipales quels sont
leur point de vue à ces candidats sur
les associations de lutte contre
l'exclusion plus particulièrement on
sans est-ce que aujourd'hui vous avez le
le sentiment que les politiques ne
répondent pas aux attentes des
associations est-ce que les politiques
soutiennent les associations développent
des choses pour permettre à ces
associations de trouver des bénévoles
alors je je je crois que les politiques
ont beaucoup de choses à faire trouver
des bénévoles c'est c'est peut-être pas
forcément le rôle mais le le rôle des
des c'est de de faciliter la vie
associative euh est-ce qu'ils répondent
à cette demande est-ce qu'il facilit
aujourd'hui les politiques les lois qui
existent facilitent cette vie des
associations en tout cas
euh je crois que le Président de la
République dans son décours d'inestiture
a lancé il y a un an et demi maintenant
à LAN un satisfait site au bénévoles et
aux associations
euh c'est vrai que aussi des
associations demandent des subventions
aux bénévoles c'est de au au pouvoirs
public ou collectivor qui est
territorial ou municipalité c'est de
plus en plus difficile d'OB tenir mais
ces dossiers sont sont étudiés je crois
que c'est très important et
l'association c'est quand même le lien
entre le public et ceux qui sont à la
tête d'une municipalité d'une
collectivité d'un conseil général ou
bien sûr de l'État on en revient à cette
campagne de communication de France
bévola qui débute plusieurs spots ont
été réalisés par des étudiants de
l'École Estienne ce sont les internautes
qui sur le site internet vont devoir
désigner le spot on regarde l'un de ces
clips qui a été réalisé par des
étudiants
en France le bénévolat c'est 12 millions
et demi de bénévoles dans plus d'un
million d'associations le bénévolat
c'est agir aider défendre le bénévola
c'est aussi
accompagner
nettoyer faire
rire
conduire
trier
correspondre inform jou participer
collectter le bénévola c'est sur
francebenevola.org francebévola du cœur
à
l'action le message à travers cette
campagne qui débute c'est le bénévolat
c'est agir aider défendre ça on s'en
doute mais c'est aussi jouer informer
faire rire c'est de montrer les
différentes facettes c'est ça le c'est
de montrer on en montre qu'une petite
partie euh parce queil y a aussi c'est
aider une association dans dans avec les
compétences que peut avoir un bénévole
dans des dans dans dans des compétences
pointues comme lestique nouvelle les
réseaux sociaux dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure ce qu'on a voulu par ces films
c'est faire participer nos bénévoles
c'est faire vivre nos bénévoles ce nos
bénévoles à nous France bénévoluss les
bénévoles de nos associations
partenaires puisque ce sont les
bénévoles d'un film fait par des
bénévoles pour des bénévoles qui à
partir depuis hier vont voir ces trois
films et puis c'est eux qui vont nous
dire voilà c'est celui-là qu'il faut
passer la réalité du du bénévola
aujourd'hui c'est c'est votre mission
c'est ça vous êtes là aujourd'hui pour
montrer cette réalité et susciter des
vocation quel est le rôle de France
bénévola le rôle de France bénévola
c'est de de faire la promotion bénévolat
de faire la valorisation du bénévolat et
aussi bien sûr de mettre en relation des
associations et des bénévoles et
effectivement de faire comprendre aux
uns aux bénévoles que finalement et
c'est l'objectif du film que c'est pas
si compliqué de faire du bénévolat quel
que soit le temps Donon nous dispose ça
peut-être 2hur par mois par exemple si
on a 2 heures par mois beaucoup
d'associations sonont contentes et c'est
aussi de d'accompagner les associations
dans leur relation avec leurs bénévoles
pour euh pour leur montrer finalement
que peut-être c'est déjà difficile de
trouver des bénévoles mais c'est encore
beaucoup plus difficile de l'écarder
donc de les fidéliser quelles sont les
associations qui attirent le plus les
bénévoles au beaucoup d'associations de
solidarité euh un peu d'associations
d'environnement euh dans le domaine de
l'accompagnement scolaire aussi beaucoup
d'associations et des associations on
aide son prochain on est plus dans
associations sportive forcément on on
est c'est un petit peu différent aussi
parceil fa une certaine compétence les
les les bénévoles en fait recherchent de
plus en plus d'actions concrètes
d'actions terrain ponctuell un peu moins
d'action régulière d'où la difficulté
d'ailleurs de trouver des responsables
associatifs euh vraiment c'est un
engagement qui est plus long on en
revient engagement qui est plus long qui
est plus long en temps mais beaucoup
plus lourd en responsabilité on parlait
de ces bénévoles est-ce qu'on peut faire
un portrait type du bénévole aujourd'hui
en 2013 il ressemble à quoi le bénévole
type le bénévole c'est quelqu'un qui a
déjà connu du bénévolat dans sa vie
personnelle dans sa vie
familiale ou par des amis euh qui a
envie et c'est les trois ingrédients
pour nous du bénévolat bien sûr de se
rendre utile
euh bien sûr de d'agir mais aussi de se
faire plaisir si ces trois ingrédients
ne sont pas runis et ben on n'est pas
vraiment motiv de il faut vraiment
qu'avant de s'engager dans association
c'est ce que nous disons à tous les
bénévoles que nous recevons que nous
recevons réfléchissez à ce que vous
voulez faire comment vous voulez le
faire quand voulezv le faire parce que
c'est le bénévole qui décide du temps
qu'il va donner et de la mission qu'il
choisit on s'engage pas à la légère il
faut développer un vrai projet en fait
il faut développer un vrai proj comme un
projet professionnel voilà tout à fait
et nous on est là à France benénéola
pour les pour les guider pour essayer de
les orienter vers les associations qui
vont avoir des projets qui correspondent
à ce qu'ils ont envie de faire et à
leurs attente et vous disposez de 80
centres départementaux 250 points
d'accueil voilà pour les chiffres
comment se porte le bénévolat sur cette
région î-defrance vous êtes le
représentant de la région î-defrance B
écoutez ça se porte bien l'image des des
chiffres que nous que je vous ai doné il
y a pas de disparité entre les régions
par rapport à ce non il y a des
différences je dire en milieu rural
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
qu'en milieu urbain mais il y a pas
vraiment de de disparité c'est peut-être
plus facile dans d'autres régions parce
que la vie parisienne euh enfin région
parisienne fait que ben il faut à
certaines heur peut-être 2hur pour venir
de la part de saint-elou ici avec
viancour euh parfois il faut une
demi-heure donc il y a quand même des
des des contraintes qui sont moins moins
fortes dans d'autrre région et pour
conclure un message je vous laisse
regarder la caméra quel message vous
passeriez à ceux qui hésitent à
s'engager au bénévol c'est facile c'est
pas compliqué venez nous voir euh on
vous expliquera ce que vous vous faire
mais réfléchissez bien au type
d'engagement que vous avez envie merci
Bernard Toubou délégé régional
îledefance 2 France bénévola et cette
campagne de communication qui débute il
y a trois spots he à sélectionner à
choisir rendez-vous sur le site internet
de l'association merci à vous on part
pour boisarcy à présent dans ce journal
avec le 7e qui était à l'honneur
aujourd'hui les arcisiens peuvent en
effet bénéficier depuis cet après-midi
d'un cinéma de manière permanente
installé à La Grange de la tremblée il
va proposer de 10 à 12 projections par
semaine le double en période de vacances
le tout doté de des dernières
technologies numériqu bien sûr Catherine
zulato Patrick Jacques de
dixmud les images de la première séance
du cinéma de boisarcy monstre académie
pour accompagner les 35 premiers
spectateurs qui attendaient l'ouverture
avec
Impa on peut pas aller forcément à
Versailles ou à Saint-Quentin donc là
c'est attendu puis vu le contexte la
médiathèque est bien le centre de
loisirs est bien donc là on attendit que
ça on est ravi de cette ouverture parce
que un cinéma de proximité comme ça
c'est super intéressant on peut venir à
pied les tarifs ont les relativement
attractif donc c'est un peu plus
familial qu'un gros que le gros cinéma
de Saint-Quentin donc c'est une très
bonne nouvelle la Ville a donc
dorenavant son cinéma de manière
permanente installée à La Grange 332
places disponibles de 10 à 12
projections par semaine et le double
pendant les vacances scolaires on a
trois styles de de de de programmation
d'abord du cinéma grand public tous les
films qui sortent actuellement grand
film une partie aressai qui est un peu
plus pointue et puis du cinéma jeune
public puisque voilà donc on a cette
trois axes de programmation une fois par
mois seront également proposés des cinés
goûtés des ciné rencontres le tout doté
des dernières innovations technologiques
le vieux projecteur 35 mm supplanté par
le fameux 4K fini les bobines place au
tout numérique aujourd'hui on reçoit un
disque dur on l'insère dans notre base
de données qui est une librairie un plus
gros disque dur une fois qu'on l'a
inséré il repart et nous après on nous
envoie une clé pour débloquer ce disque
dur parce qu'il est crypté on on peut
pas le diffuser tant qu'on a pas eu
cette clé et après c'est simple suffit
d'appuyer sur play et puis c'est parti
la salle de cinéma est municipale elle
intègre le réseau local premier plan lui
permettant des diffusions pour les
scolaires les tarifs sont compris entre
4 et 6
€. si vous êtes amateur du Japon de sa
culture le centre Alfred de Vigny à
voisin le Bretonneux consacrera la
première semaine d'octobre au pays du
soleil levant conférence et cours de
saakéologie au programme mais aussi
peinture sur éventail et aiku
calligraphie japonaise plus
d'informations sur le site internet de
l'association ce dimanche un défilé de
voiture de collection était organisé
entre Montini le Bretonneux et
Versailles l'occasion d'aller à la
rencontre de ses collectionneurs une
balade qu'on suivi pour nous Olivier
Maniscalco et Jonathan
villman la 27e édition Automoto rétro se
tenait le weekend dernier sur le site du
château de La Coudre à montigé le
Bretonneau amateur et promeneur étai au
rendez-vous pour apprécier le
vrombissement des moteurs et les belles
carrosseries parmi eux Luc
collectionneur du valde Marne et
propriétaire d'une Renault Viva 6 de
1931 c'est la toute première fois que je
défile oui sur cette journée oui a
énormément de manifestations qui sont
tout au long de l'année bon on fait pas
on les fait pas toutes forcément
mais on en fait quand même
relativement souvent quand l'occasion se
présente alors la passion de
l'automobile c'est c'est un jour avec
ses parents on est sur la route et puis
on voit un engin un petit peu
particulier et puis on dit mais c'est
quoi et puis après on épluche et puis un
jour ben on ouvre la porte d'un garage
et il y en a une qui s'offre à vous donc
bah vous faites le pas puis voilà
passion je dirais plus une folie une
folie parce que
T tout collectionneur quel qu'il soit
c'est forcément une grande folie toute
la matinée les chromes ont rutilé le
long des routes de Montini au château de
Versailles avec un arrêt au Petit
Trianon Mustang de chevaux alpines
traction et autres mg composa un cortège
de près de 200 voitures sur l'ensemble
de la
journée je vous propose à présent de
revoir l'image du jour c'est
l'autopartage à Saint-Quentin en Yveline
qui fête ses un an le 18 septembre 2012
50 tzy de Renault été proposé à la
location moyennant moins de 30 centimes
la minute des véhicules biplace à
prendre et à redéposer au coin de votre
rue localisable grâce à votre téléphone
portable si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez vous inscrire pour bénéficier de
ce service rendez-vous notamment dans la
boutique teway situé à la gare de
Montini le Bretonneux la gare de Montini
on y reste justement puisqu'elle vient
d'être inaugurée aujourd'hui avec 25000
usagers par jour et sans rénovation
importante depuis 1975 les locaux
étaient devenu plus que véuste les
travaux en extérieur en revanche vont se
poursuivre jusqu'en 2017 toutes les
précisions avec Anthony Resche et
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud les élus locaux découvrent la
nouvelle gare de 50 ans en Yveline la
Salle des pas perdu est est enfin doté
d'une Signaléthique claire l'espace a
été décloisonné et les usagers peuvent
désormais acheter des billets
Transiliens ou grandes lign sans
chercher leur chemin au point de vue de
l'affichage beaucoup mieux c'est vrai
qu'au début quand je suis arrivé ah
j'étais complètement paumé c'est clair
que même au niveau infrastructure rien à
dire c'est super on a implanté des
nouveaux panneaux
d'information pour les trains donc pour
indiquer d'où partent les trains et
l'information vraiment sur le trafic qui
ont aussi contribué à faciliter bah la
gestion
dans cette gare la gare cquentinoise
n'avait pas connu de rénovation
importante depuis
1975 avec 25000 usagers par jour le
lifting de la station était devenu vital
on a refait le revêtements de sol les
plafonds tout ce qui est lié à la
sécurité l'éclairage la signalitique
l'ensemble des modalités de circulation
verticale escalator on a mis à niveau le
parc des
ascenseurs les travaux de réaménagement
de la Salle des pas perdu s'élèvent à 1
800000 € financé à 50 % par la Région
Île-de-France et à 50 % par la SNCF à
l'extérieur la rue Joë lotel et l'avenue
de la gare sont encore en chantier à
l'horizon
2017-208 la gare de 50 ans en Yveline
pourrait voir sa passerelle totalement
réaménagé pour donner un autre accès
auok je vous retrouve demain 18h en
direct pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité locale n'oubliez pas les
replay sur notre site et puis vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux et
si vous nous suivez en direct sachez que
dans un instant vous retrouverez
aurellia debici pour kiosk le magazine
culture de la rédaction excellente
soirée